[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
can you believe can you believe how
quickly they set this up in that time it
took me to walk from there to over here
right and it all comes in a little pill
except that plate dropped some water on
it all right now ladies and gentlemen I
am not sure what teams these mascots are
from they're that bad but but first up
on the list this doesn't sound promising
as a mascot called the 7-eleven burrito
is going to try and blend up to burrito
that's been left out too long it's a
burrito from the late 80s from 7-eleven
and go for it burrito try your best come
on
[Music]
[Applause]
all right she is back go to your neutral
corner she's back in the news after
recently posing nude and creating a big
controversy give it up for the Octomom
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
come on go for it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's just throwing those babies into a
pile what are you giving them to
audience members for giving babies
Albania audience members all right here
we go ladies and jumpin you've all
wanted to see a Greek mythological
creature who was dressed like a [ __ ] I
mean who doesn't so please welcome the
Minotaur in a miniskirt
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right here's one the surge protector
that's got way too many cords let's
check it out
whenever you're ready surge protector go
for it
[Music]
[Applause]
terrible terrible idea for this next
mascot the guy taking a webcam photo of
his own penis may I
there you go sorry to interrupt you guys
but let's see you dunk this basketball
[Music]
now not even close
roster
[Applause]
and finally ladies and gentlemen the
little person with 14-foot arms the
little person quit sports and whenever
you're ready little person go for it
Oh
[Music]
Oh
haha his can-do spirit
there they are the n-c-double-a mascots
that you've never done